ساعات فقط. فماذا لو كان هذا
الشاب انت بعدما كان التفاوض مع
باعتماد لجنة اممية مختصة قرار
فلسطين بطلب فتوى قانونية من
والبدناء بين ترشيق الوزن او
التقاعد وذلك بحسب تقارير صحفية.
الخصوم الى رشدهم. هنا انطلقت في
مدينة جوخاي جنوبي الصين فعاليات
يطلقون اصوات عواء خلال خطاب
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بقمة
المسؤولون الامريكيون يراقبون
تهديدا متزايدا من طهران للعراق.
وايران وبتدخل امريكي مع تراكم
الخلافات في منطقة. ويبدو ان
لامريكا وتايوان. حيث اعلنت
وزارة الدفاع التايوانية ان
الاسرائيلي يعتبره خرقا
دبلوماسيا. طفلة من اسرة عربية
تطالب باطلاق سراح المعتقلين
السياسيين في مصر نشطاء مناخ
مهاجرة سلمها لزوجين مثليين في
السويد ليتبنيانها. مظاهرات
موسكو يعد خسارة في نظر الغرب.
صار اليوم مطلبهم الاول ليقولها
مؤسسي اف تي اكس بخسارته خمسة
عشر مليار دولار من ثروته خلال
بالاحلام. استعراض للقوة
الصينية. التهديدات وحدها لا
المتحدة خطابات الجماعات
اليمينية المتطرفة في اسرائيل
بينما نشرت القناة الثانية عشر
العبرية تقريرا رفعت عنه السرية
رسالة بكين لم تصل بعد. فهل يرد
الصينيون برسالة اقوى? العراق
والمترهلين ومن استعدادات الجيوش
الاجنبية الى استعدادات من نوع
عدد من القواعد العسكرية. حتى ان
واشنطن جعلت نوويتين تحلقان فوق
الشرق الاوسط برسالة تهديد
لطهران. كل ذلك دفع بالجيشين
امام الدولار الامريكي كذلك ازمة
اللاجئين وعلاقات واشنطن ببكين
لتعود صافرات الانذار وتدوي في
معظم مدن ومناطق اوكرانيا تأهبا
الروسية الحديثة ستصل الى
اوكرانيا خلال الاشهر المقبلة
الروسية الاوكرانية الا ان
مسؤولا امريكيا عاد التنبيه الى
للرئيس الصيني. تايوان ترفض
مقترح اقامة دولة واحدة. يبدو ان
بكين هذا العام عن احدث
اصداراتها من الطائرات المقاتلة
الامن الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف ان
موسكو لم تستخدم بعد ترسانتها
ارتكبته بلاده بحق اسرائيل مؤخرا
يمكن ان يؤثر على علاقتهما كييف
على تدمير التحالفات المعادية
بينما قال ديمتري جوزن الذي
استعادتها خرسون ها هي اوكرانيا
تحشد قواتها على خط جبهة زبروشيا
ذلك للروس ليخرج مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني ويتحدث عن خطأ فادح
يعيد ساعة الصفر. انشغلت دول
العالم على مدار اشهر بالحرب
العراق سيكون ساحة لهذه الحرب.
فيالى تعاسة الشعب العراقي الذي
امكانية اندلاع حرب في الشرق
الاوسط اطرافها السعودية والعراق
مسيرة العابرة للقارات. هناك
كشفت بكين النقاب عن اسلحة فائقة
يعتمد بشدة على القوة الامريكية
لردع اي نزاع عسكري محتمل على
جزيرة تايوان. واضافت الوزارة ان
عشر طائرات حلقت في اليوم الماضي
تداعيات سياسية. ومع قرار موسكو
وقف عن القارة الاوروبية وهي
الاحداث والتطورات. اعلنت
الخارجية الامريكية ان الولايات
موسكو الى التعامل مع المفاوضات
بحسن نية. ليرد نائب رئيس مجلس
سبيل شن ضربات ناجحة على مواقع
نووية ايرانية. لا مكان للبدناء
انسحابها من خرسون والدفاع
الروسية تؤكد استمرار العمليات
اكثر من سبعمائة واربعين شركة من
نحو ثلاث واربعين دولة. وكشفت
الاتحاد. وكثرت التحديات في
اروقته. لا سيما وان الاتحاد
الدورة الرابعة عشرة لمعرض الصين
الدولي للطيران وتشارك في المعرض
تنفع صارت موضة قديمة. فلا بد
لاستعراض القوة احيانا ليعود
نتائج السلبية كاستيراد الغاز
باربعة اضعاف. فهل تحاول واشنطن
على قوائم الارهاب وفلسطين ترحب.
امريكا تطلب التفاوض مع روسيا.
لا يدري من اين ستأتيه الضربة
القادمة? صحيفة بوليتكو.
فلنصفق جميعا لهذه المسرحية
الهزلية. فيما رحبت فلسطين
محكمة العدل الدولية حول ماهية
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والكيان
الصينية على الجزيرة مؤكدة
استقلالها التام عنها في تحد
الجميع ان الحرب التي بدأت
بالصواريخ المرعبة سيطفئها توقيع
المناخ. نهاية درامية لملك
العملات الشاب الثلاثيني الشهير
مضيفة انه تم ادراج المنظمة
الصهيونية على قوائم الارهاب.
وروسيا ترد. نحن الى هذه اللحظة
لم نستخدم قوتنا والكيان
فوق خط الوسط في مضيق تايوان
الذي يفصل الجزيرة عن البر
الرئيسي الصيني. بينما شددت
تايوان على عدم قبولها للسيادة
اخر للجيش العراقي. الجيش
العراقي يخير ضباطه المترهلين
الجيش الصيني اطلق ستا وثلاثين
طائرة مقاتلة وقاذف قنابل قرب
لا احد يعلم متى ستنتهي في
اوكرانيا لكن اليوم او غدا سيعلم
من طراز وايو تونتي. بكين لم
تكتفي بالمعرض لايصال رسالتها
الامريكي والسعودي الى رفع
مستويات تأهب الاسبوع الماضي.
حول استعداد سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي لتذليل العقبات في
حيث تنشر الولايات المتحدة
الالاف من القوات والافراد في
العراقي نفسه من اصحاب الاوزان
الزائدة. وامريكا تضع الصهاينة
المتحدة وحلفاؤها يشعرون بالقلق
من ان دعم اوكرانيا سيهلكهم
جورنال. ونقلت الصحيفة عن احد
الغربيين قوله نقول للاوكرانيين
التملص عن دعم كييف بسبب كل تلك
الخسائر? خسائر واشنطن تقابلها
التي تهدد القارة العجوز يبدو ان
اوروبا سترى جيشها الموحد فقط
سوليفان عليه ان يفكر في مواقف
تفاوضية واقعية بحسب وول ستريت
القدرات بينها وحش الصين الجوي
وهي طائرة النقل العسكري الصيني
معضلة غير مسبوقة اضافة الى
تراجع اليورو الى ادنى مستوياته
والسياسة والاقتصاد. الامر الذي
تسبب في اتساع الخلافات داخل
اراضيه. وكانت محاولة لتشكيل جيش
اوروبي لم تبصر النور بسبب
الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يعد كما كان
سابقا فاليوم به ازمات الامن
الكاملة خلال عملياتها العسكرية
في اوكرانيا ولكن كل شيء باوانه.
وانضمت بذلك لروسيا وايران.
وماذا عن المصفحات ايها
القتالية في جميع المحاور. يخرج
وزير الخارجية الاوكراني ويدعو
صوتت ضد اسرائيل حول قرار
قانونية الاحتلال في فلسطين
يترأس فريقا من المستشارين الروس
في اقليم دومبس ان الاسلحة
لضربات روسية انتقاما لخسارتها
خرسون. باي باي جيش اوروبا.
لافتا الى ان بلاده تقاتل حلف
الناتو والغرب وحدها وهي قادرة
وزلنسكي يتعهد بمواصلة طرد
القوات الروسية خارج بلاده بعد
الاوكرانيون ميدانيا? الوضع
تغيروا يوما بعد يوم فبعد
لم يعرف كيف وصلت الى اوكرانيا.
والسؤال كيف سيبرر الاسرائيليون
لا تزود اوكرانيا بالسلاح كشفت
هيئة البث الاسرائيلية عن وجود
اقتصاديا وسيقضي على مخزونهم من
الاسلحة وبعيدا عن الاسلحة كذلك
على طرف ورقة ومن هذا المنطلق
اعلنت امريكا. وخلال اجتماعه
الاخير مع زيلانسكي اقترح مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
والمسؤولون الامريكيون يراقبون
العراق بينما يغربل الجيش
المقاتلات فوق تايوان. وحلم
الجيش الاوروبي في مهب الريح
للروس من الدول الغربية. صدمة
الغرب بسبب الاقتصاد الروسي
غريب. الصين تستعرض اقوى
الطائرات امام العالم سربا من
الاسرائيلي في موقف صعب امام
موسكو والاقتصاد الروسي في تصاعد
تقابلها صدمة اخرى ولكن للكيان
الاسرائيلي. فبرغم تأكيدها انها
مصفحات اسرائيلية الصنع يستغلها
الاوكران في حربهم ضد روسيا ولكن
ويجب ان تفكروا قبل فوات الاوان.
هكذا قالت الولايات المتحدة
وهي حقيقة مرة لا تستطيع اوروبا
انكارها والنفط اهم رافد اقتصادي
ارباح موسكو ورغم العقوبات
الغربية القاسية منذ تسعة اشهر
نيويورك تايمز تعلنها. ارتفاع
قيمة الصادرات الروسية بعد الحرب
سيكون من الجيد ان نبدأها مبكرا.
نعم يا اصدقاء. فالولايات
المحللون بلسان مصري. ما كم
الاول يا جماعة?
ان الامر متروك لهم ليقرروا متى
سيبدأون محادثات السلام لكن
لاوكرانيا بينما تتغير الاوضاع
في ارض المعارك فما الذي يجري